مشاهدينا تتوالى الازمات في سوريا فبعد
اسبوعين على الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
الجنوب التركي وشمال السوري تلاه امس
زلزال اخر ما فام حاله الهلع عند السكان
وزاد الحاجه لمزيد من المساعدات في وقت لا
تزال السياسه تتغلب على الاوضاع الانسانيه
مساله تحرك المساعدات معقده منذ عام 2014
فيما كان النزاع السوري في اشده وخاصه
شمال غرب البلاد الخاضع لسيطره المعارضه
والذي يقتله اكثر من اربعه ملايين شخص رغم
تصاعد التوتر بين النظام والمعارضه انذاك
كانت المساعدات الامميه تمر لسوريا دون
اذن من دمشق عبر اربع نقاط حدوديه وهي باب
الهوى وباب السلامه للحدوديان مع تركيا
وليعروبيه باقصى الشرق على الحدود
العراقيه بالاضافه الى معبر الرمثا
الحدوطي مع الاردن مع مرور الوقت واشتداد
الحرب تقلصات طرق المساعد تدريجيا الى
معبر باب الهواء فقط لمده سنين حتى وقوع
الزلزال الزلزال اندفع الامم المتحده الى
مطالبه النظام السوري باعاده فتح معابر
اضافيه غير باب الهوى لتسهيل وصول
المساعدات الى مناطق المعارضه دون قيد او
شرط ليتم الاعلان لاحقا عن فتح معبريه باب
السلامه من منطقه اعزاز شمال حلب والراعي
في ريف حلب امام مساعدتها لمده ثلاثه اشهر
بعدما حصلت على موافقته دمشق